Her low freak bitches.
What's funny is it grown man crying when he shouldn't be crying?
Yeah,
that's what's funny.
absolutely.
Yeah.
And it's,
you know,
it's like there's still an instinct.
You still have like a kind of a knee jerk instinct to things sometimes it just
makes you laugh if you share that feeling at the,
at the wrong time when you were immature.
Yeah.
And then they'll use charge.
And then the flip side is,
uh,
is the right man.
I like,
they're,
they're calling everybody snowflakes and then you say one thing that they don't
want to hear and they want you all Fox News.
Talk about snowflakes.
Why shep Smith teach it.
Go with Megan Kelly to m and the lame stream NBC and you go,
doesn't that make you,
doesn't that make you a snowflake now?
And then same thing happened with Chris Wallace.
Shepard Smith said that interview with Reince Priebus and people were like,
get him out of here.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Chris Wallace,
his,
you know,
his dad was Mike Wallace.
He's actually a journalist.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Well,
it's a weird time when you see journalists getting excluded from press gaggles
when you get the New York Times.
And uh,
who else was it?
It was an la times la times and then there was another big one.
Oh,
CNN,
CNN.
Fuck the fuck man.
What the fuck I you remember when Obama was considering removing Fox News from
something because Fox News is essentially propaganda.
If you listen to Sean Hannity,
I,
I've heard Sean Hannity is a wonderful man.
I've heard he's a really nice guy when you meet him,
but that mother fucker is spewing straight hot propaganda.
He was the best point man.
After the grab my pussy shit came up,
he was the best because he will just went fucking straight to Bengazi.
He went straight to the email scandal.
Any fucking hammered it constantly to the point where,
you know,
locker room talk aside,
he start,
let me go get you certainly say that was inappropriate.
Well,
let's get to the facts.
Your,
let's get to what's important and just Bam,
Bam.
He's,
he's a big Trump ally.
He's good.
It's as good at what he does.
Oh,
he was very good at what he does.
But I mean,
when that was going on w against Obama,
they were like,
look,
why the fuck are we having these people?
Even why we even pretending they're press,
this is not journalism.
These,
this is a propaganda network.
And if everybody was like,
Whoa,
you remember?
It's like 2009 yeah.
And Obama almost had them removed,
but people protested.
He's like,
all right,
fine.
Not Trump.
No.
He's like,
not only that,
I'm not even going to the press correspondents' dinner.
Fuck.
That to me is you talked about being a pussy dude.
Like you're like,
you're scared,
you're scared to get made.
That's him get being scared yet.
And I was thinking the whole time,
I'm like,
oh,
what can median gets to do that?
That's a great gig.
Fuck that Gig.
That guy will go after you.
Well,
it's a district.
That's the problem is you make fun of that dude.
And then like you'll all of a sudden,
like you have like you're getting audit right.
And more than audited,
man,
more than audited.
They're probably search your emails and find some incriminating shit that you
might've did when you were in high school.
But then,
but then part of me is like kind of worth it.
The get stand standup kind of kind of stand up on the stage next to Trump and
just be like,
dude,
come on.
Yeah,
you would definitely get mad press for doing it.
Well,
but yeah,
he would,
he would go,
I don't know.
He doesn't handle it well.
Do you remember when Obama was a roast him and he just sat there and you have it
his face?
Yeah,
I know it's,
it's,
it's a weird time,
man.
That was like when Obama said,
uh,
we have video of my actual birth for the first time we're going to release and
they go to the lion king over the lion king cartoon was hilarious.
Obama was fucking good at that.
But I'm really pretty funny.
He's a funny president.
Yeah.
You mean?
I just,
I still to this day,
I think that he's probably as far as like as a human being,
not,
not as like,
I hate president,
just speeches because I hate,
I hate that whole political talk.
I hate the way people talk.
I know like they're not a real person and he is like the king of the paws man.
He's a big fake.
It's stupid artistic pause and pause.
Well,
I mean he's just good at that kind of shit.
And there's a thing too that I don't particularly like that,
but I get it.
But I mean as far as like being like a representative of the country and the guy
was intelligent,
well read,
I forget his policies aside.
There's something about who the guy who was in charge is what it says about the
rest of us and what it says about the rest of us now.
I said we're a disorganized mess.
And that's really what it says.
Yeah,
it's,
it's definitely a,
uh,
I could tell you this though,
Trump is not wrong about CNN hating him.
Like he's not wrong.
You Watch if you watch the election and everything leading up to the election,
they did not like him,
even though even though images that use of him and they were pretty openly
against him.
And look,
I want,
like I said,
I worked at the daily show,
I watched a lot of CNN,
I watch a lot of MSNBC.
There's problems.
I have problems with all of those cable news now.
Good for you because you should.
And I really think that like the cult of personality media thing,
my biggest issue with cable news is that there were in the same rating system as
like the Big Bang theory.
You know what I'm saying?
That's it.
And it's like they're trying to get
no,
but they're trying to get numbers,
man.
That's all they're trying to do.
Obviously the goal of Sean Hannity show or,
or,
uh,
[inaudible] any of these shows is to get people to watch so they can sell ad
time cause so they can make money.
So that's my issue with it more than,
you know,
they're like,
a lot of them were bad at journalism.
I mean,
you know,
I,
it's hard for me to forget things like balloon boy when like we're at war in
Afghanistan and Iraq and like,
uh,
they think a kid stuck in a weather balloon and we have like seven hours of
coverage of a weather balloon floating down the street with a live chopper
covers.
And then it turned out the kid was hiding,
the dad was a prankster and that done that before.
Whatever.
Why,
why did I have to watch that for four hours?
You know what I'm saying?
So it's like there,
if a shiny thing happens,
they run towards the shiny thing they do.
They're immature.
They're looking for ratings,
they're looking to be the first,
they never talk about there's like Flint,
Michigan,
right?
When's the last time,
like people that don't have water still and they live in America still,
but the media is not talking about it.
You know,
they're talking right now about Kelly Conway putting her feet,
feet,
feet up,
shoes on.
It's what I want to know.
But then another words,
God Damn White House,
couch pitch.
So if they get,
they get,
they get well,
that's what people are mad about it.
They're like,
they're like,
that's disrespectful.
If a guy was sitting like that,
but you got to imagine the Scotch guarded that shit.
If Obama was sitting like that on the couch,
do you have any gay rumors would come out about him if Michelle Obama was
sitting like that anywhere?
Oh yeah.
People be so angry.
I would say about people,
the things people say about Michelle Obama has her shoes on.
Oh boy,
that is just unamerican shit,
bubblegum all over the fucking White House couch,
dare you lady dog shit.
And bubblegum.
It's a real problem with what the news is because it's not really the news.
It's an entertainment show featuring events in the news.
Right?
And it's,
they're a hundred percent bias.
There's no real journalism on television when it comes to TV news,
PBS,
maybe they're super liberal,
but they're also very boring.
Yeah.
In other words,
they're not trying to Zazi here's what's happening.
That's what we need though.
You need to be able to formulate your own opinions and when you're being steered
in one way or another,
whether it's steered by bill O'Reilly or steered by someone on the left,
it's this,
who the fuck is like a big reporter for CNN?
I don't even know any Anderson Cooper.
That's it.
We'll both it up.
Wolf Blitzer,
I saw Wolf Blitzer the other day in Vegas.
I ran into him.
I got intimidated.
I was going to say hi,
but I'm like,
maybe it doesn't like me.
Maybe hit for hookers with him.
He was walking into the Bellagio and high five them.
Nobody wants to smoke a joint.
The only thing I will say about Fox is like their opinion guys o' Reilly
Hannity,
they kind of have them under opinion.
Right.
Versus like Anderson Cooper is like news,
you know?
So it's like,
it's like,
but do you think Anderson,
I think Anderson Cooper,
like my take on him is clearly,
he's very left wing.
Right?
He's a gay guy,
you know?
I mean he's a,
he's a,
but it's also a Vanderbilt.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
And he also worked for the CIA when he was in college that I did not know.
The big concern is that Anderson Cooper embedded CIA journalist.
Yeah,
that's the big CIA conspiracy theory.
You didn't know that.
No,
I did not know.
I would imagine that once you work for the CIA,
you're in the fucking CIA.
Imagine you always have a little contact.
I have a friend who used to be in the CIA and I still consider him in the CIA
and you know,
I mean,
I know another guy whose dad was in the CIA is a fucking dad's still in the CIA.
Essentially.
You figure you got to know a couple people over at this.
I like,
I don't know.
I don't have any CIA contacts.
You know?
It's like I used to work there.
You'd probably have a few,
and this is a shitty comparison,
but if I left the UFC,
I'd still be with the UFC.
You know what I mean?
Like there's,
there's like,
there's this,
there's a,
a giant bond that you've got to have with the fucking Central Intelligence
Agency.
You know,
you don't fuck with those guys.
You don't fuck them over and if they call you,
you answer the Goddamn phone hook.
Yeah,
you did.
Yeah.
I'm still like I,
that's why I really got word of that when Trump was being so hard on the
intelligence.
Crazy
dude.
Like,
I don't know,
man,
like all of those guys in the intelligence community,
like they're the reasons we're safe.
Okay.
Yeah.